I was really excited to hear that we
were jumping five years ahead because I
mean now I'm getting to play a little
closer to my age not exactly my age but
closer it's nice to have mature
conversations and like out of a high
school setting so you know it's so funny
because the writers have us drinking in
almost every scene to show that we're
you know age-appropriate but it's been
fun I think all of us have had a really
good time and it's fun to kind of
develop a new sense of the character but
I think for the viewers it's also
awesome because a lot of our viewers
started pretty young and they've grown
up with the show and now they get to be
going through the same things that
they're going through I think it's
really great and relatable for those
viewers it's just fun to have different
sets and be able to you know act like we
do outside of the set which is a little
bit more mature a little bit older a
little bit wiser so I was really excited
for it so we're still gonna have that
drama and all the cliffhangers and and
everything but we're gonna get to see
how these girls have grown up and how
they've evolved and what kind of jobs
they have and their relationship there's
new relationships and we're introducing
new characters we have new secrets from
each other so the really exciting thing
is to get to watch who these people are
now and how they interact now that five
years have gone by and a lot of stuff
has happened in those five years